hey guys I'm Veronica I'm Vanessa we're
the Merrill twins and these are our
first the Merrill twins have gone from
filming a build-a-bear to starting their
own fashion line we'll talk about how to
tell these sisters apart and what sad
situation almost prevented them from
starting their YouTube channel Plus find
out why you never see their mom in their
videos this is also proof that it is
okay to be yourself the Merrill twins
know that getting a ton of clicks online
can translate to very real dollars
ending up in their bank accounts their
YouTube channel has over five million
subscribers and they gain about 1000
more every day their fans watch their
content about five hundred and twenty
thousand times per day meaning their
videos have been seen over a billion
times since they started their channel
each one of those clicks adds up to
about 2600 per day or 950 thousand
dollars per year from YouTube alone all
in all these twin sisters have
accumulated a net worth of approximately
4.5 million been struggling to find out
where the Merrill twins go to college
there's a good reason this info isn't
readily accessible
according to Vanessa and Veronica
they've been purposely vague about their
chosen school in an attempt to protect
their own safety they revealed that they
were attending school somewhere in
California or forced to delay their
degrees at least for now
the twins started out classes online
which were much easier to fit into their
pack schedules but when they
transitioned to in-person learning they
found it difficult to balance school and
their careers although they claimed to
be good students they admitted that
their GPAs were suffering from extended
absences so they decided to take a break
and protect their grades until they were
ready to commit we want to continue our
education I think it's very important
and I'm learning anyway but getting
their degrees could ultimately help
their careers Vanessa wants to study TV
production while Veronica is set on a
career as a screenwriter honestly I'm
really proud of like all the videos we
do me to put a lot of work to
of them everyone knows Veronica and
Vanessa Merrill
but there's a reason their dad Paul is
known as the third Merrill twin he's
committed to their daughter's careers
and is always there to film and provide
tons of hilarious dad jokes when the
occasion calls for it Paul even moved
their family home from Kansas City
Missouri to Los Angeles so the twins
could have a better shot at stardom to
afford the change in scenery Paul had to
sell everything even his beloved boat he
also paid for his kids first camera even
though the girls were disappointed
apparently they wanted a Barbie brand
camera and were upset that their dad
bought them a much better quality one
week out my first video as our first
sketch banessa and Veronica are lucky to
have the support of their family and
fans but not everyone thought they would
make it big when they started talking
about creating their own videos their
classmates were less than encouraging
after Paul hooked them up with a proper
camera in sixth grade
the twins made their own horror movie
which they admit wasn't the best but it
definitely didn't justify the bullying
they endured from their classmates which
almost made them quit acting altogether
the teasing got worse when the family
announced that they were moving to LA
but Veronica says they refused to let
anything stop them from achieving their
dreams we all loved the Meryl twins but
let's talk about an amazing four-legged
member of their family their dog tiger
he's named after the University of
Missouri Tigers and the twins described
him as a diva who loves begging for
treats his favorite hobbies are eating
and sleeping and honestly saying the
twins claim that their mother is Tigers
favorite person in the world followed by
Vanessa
Veronica admits her relationship with
Tiger suffers because she can't resist
blowing little raspberries on his cue a
little tummy yes yes you have
one of the most frequently searched
questions about these famous sisters is
regarding their ethnicity according to
Veronica and Vanessa their Spanish
Portuguese Filipino Irish Mexican German
and probably a whole bunch of others
they'd be interested in doing a DNA test
someday but for now their knowledge on
family history is pretty limited
although they can understand a little
bit of Spanish English is the only
language both twins speak fluently
[Music]
another question the twins frequently
filled is which one of them is the
oldest Veronica was born first and there
were some complications when it came to
delivering Vanessa
apparently the umbilical cord was
pressing against her neck which made it
difficult to breathe she was born via
emergency c-section a whole 45 minutes
after Veronica although she's fine now
Vanessa had some problems with her lungs
which required careful monitoring in the
hospital
Vanessa had some breathing troubles
early on but now veronica is the one who
suffers from a condition yes this
cheese-loving twin is unfortunately
lactose intolerant it's a shame since
she can't get enough of her favorite
foods including mac and cheese cheesy
potatoes and parmesan covered pasta
Vanessa says that she's slightly lactose
intolerant but it's not a big deal
since she doesn't eat a lot of dairy
anyway but even though she knows she'll
pay for it later
Veronica admits she often can't help
snacking on her favorite cheese's moving
to LA was a huge change for Veronica and
Vanessa and they were used to being
bullied back at their own school so they
were relieved to make their first friend
in LA who was an actor you might have
heard of named Cameron Boyce the twins
claim Cameron made them feel welcomed
and accepted and described him as a
genuinely kind and loving person they
thanked him for having a positive impact
in their lives and were devastated when
he passed away
due to complications from epilepsy use
Twitter too for Q&A
our Veronica Merrill and Aaron Burris
more than just good friends
well a ton of their fans seem to think
so and they even called a couple Ron Ron
according to Veronica the two of them
are just good friends and there's
nothing romantic between them but she
also admitted that they send each other
good morning text so we'll let you draw
your own conclusions there since he's 31
years old he's quite a bit older than
Veronica but the two of them are
certainly close to one another
many fans fell in love with the idea of
Vanessa Merrill and Christian Seavey
after twin my heart but were they able
to make it last according to them they
ultimately realized that they're better
off as friends while they're still close
they claim to be strictly platonic some
fans speculate that she's seeing Bryce
hall but this also hasn't been confirmed
during a lie-detector test Vanessa said
she doesn't have a boyfriend and the
test determined that was the truth and
it might stay that way for a while
although the twins are putting together
a second season of twin my heart it'll
focus on helping their friends Nessa and
Franny Arrieta find love just because
Veronica and Vanessa are twins doesn't
mean they need to find other twins to go
out with they've heard plenty of rumors
about themselves but one they find
baffling is that they're involved with
the Dolin twins both Merril twins claim
that this isn't true and they have no
idea why so many fans seem to be
convinced that it is it's not even a
dream I never even like dreamt of it I
couldn't like you know
we all know Paul is the unofficial third
Merrill twin but what about their mother
there's a lot of speculation about her
with fans wondering if she's still alive
and whether or not she's still married
to Paul but thankfully Wendy Merrill is
very much alive and still happily
married to the twins father so why does
she strictly spend time behind the
scenes it turns out Wendy isn't
fascinated with the spotlight like the
rest of her family and hates being in
front of the camera according to the
twins their mom doesn't even like posing
for family photos if she can help it
just because Wendy Merrill is a more
conservative member of the family
doesn't mean she doesn't help out in
fact she actually quit her old job in
order to support her daughters she used
to work for a local school district
before the twins convinced her to give
it all up and come work for them when
Paul is in charge of the camera
Wendy works to keep the twins of
schedules straight handle their emails
and help them quote be same even though
bronica and Vanessa are identical twins
there's one super easy trick to tell
them apart vanessa has dimples on each
of her cheeks while Veronica only has a
single dimple on the left side of her
face this tiny divot is a huge clue
about which twin is which but according
to their dad they have plenty of
differences in their personalities
he claims that Veronica is the more
serious twin and is a bigger risk taker
behind the scenes
Vanessa's major trait is her creativity
and she's not afraid to be a little
crazy on camera the Merrill twins
definitely aren't hurting for screen
time now but their career started out
with surprisingly humble beginnings
before they built a YouTube empire they
start in a build-a-bear commercial back
in 2008 since then the twins have
appeared in Jane the Virgin faking it
the standoff hyperlinked and like a boss
Vanessa was cast as Olivia on swished
which should be released in 2022 hey
guys make sure you watch the premiere of
Jane the virgin at 9/8 central on the CW
network
we all know these two sisters make
amazing videos but that's not all
they're awesome at ever since they were
kids
they've been interested in the world of
fashion and making sure they're dressed
as stylish ly as possible Vanessa says
that they use their grandmother's sewing
machine to create clothes for their
dolls using scraps of fabric eventually
the girls graduated to making their own
clothes and did their best to keep up
with the latest celebrity trends now the
twins are trendsetters themselves with
their own fashion line called true IMG
seeing their style come to life has been
a dream come true for Veronica Vanessa
and their fans
if you thought twins tell each other
everything
think again Veronica and Vanessa were
asked questions while hooked up to a lie
detector test and some surprising truths
came out according to the test
Vanessa believes the Veronica has a
better singing voice but she thinks she
is the superior singer the test added
that Veronica isn't even the funniest
person Vanessa knows and that Vanessa
really doesn't think her dad's jokes are
funny she admitted that she finds them
annoying but isn't that what Dad jokes
are for no matter how many videos you've
seen of the meril twins meeting them in
person is something else entirely
according to these sisters their fans
are usually surprised by how short they
both are in real life
both Veronica and Vanessa are just over
five feet tall or five too depending on
the show as they like to say they
believe they look a lot taller on camera
which explains why they're short sizes
are in them so many second looks but the
twins admit that they aren't adverse to
wearing platform soles to give
themselves a little bit of a boost
clever their careers have heard of them
a huge bank account balance and some
official awards they've been nominated
for shorty awards Streamy Awards and
Teen Choice Awards so far they've taken
home two streamys and a shorty and
they're up for a 20/20 Kids Choice Award
which show or movie do you think the
meryl twins would make a great addition
to let us know what you think in the
comments section below and don't forget
to click on the subscribe button for
more new videos from us here at the
things bye for now